みなさん、タマネギ丸かじりしたことあります？
やってみますか！
...甘い！
私のベロメーターで糖度11度、全く辛くない！
これは、「スマイルボール」という新しい品種です。
私のところで交配で作出しました。
私は植物育種研究所、岡本大作と申します。
「育種」というのは、「品種改良」ということです。
植物を、掛け合わせをして、新しい品種を作ります。
みなさん「何だ、タマネギか〜」と思ったかもしれません。
ちなみに私が食べたタマネギのこの部分って、
葉っぱだと思います？茎だと思います？
根っこだと思います？
手あげてもらいますよ！
私覚えてますから！（笑）
葉っぱだと思う人！...ちょっとだけ。
茎だと思う人！...あ、けっこう多い！
根っこだと思う人！...けっこういます！
答え言います。葉っぱです！
みなさん、ほとんど大外れです。（笑）
私の友だちも言うんですよ。
「おまえ、タマネギ研究して、スーパーに行っても
タマネギなんか1種類しか売ってないじゃないか」って。
ちょっと悔しいですよね〜。
もともと、野菜なんてものは世の中になかったんです。
何千年も前に道端に生えてたり、
山に生えてるようなものを人間が食べ始めて、
「ああ、ちょっと食べれるな。もうちょっと大きく
したいな。もうちょっと食べれる部分を大きくしたいな。」
といって、何千年にも渡って、実は品種改良してきてたんです。
で、タマネギなんですけれど、
タマネギの原産地は中央アジアと言われています。
今でも中央アジアに行くと、
ネギの、まあネギというか雑草みたいなのが
岩場に生えてるんですって！
私は行ったことないです。
おそらくそういうものを人間が食べ始めて、
次は、エジプトにタマネギが行きました。
これ、エジプトのピラミッドの中の壁画。
私美術館でちょっと見つけてきました。
美術館で、私の知識では、
エジプトのピラミッドの労働者に賃金と一緒に
タマネギを渡してたという記述があるそうです。
もしかして壁画にタマネギが描いてあるんじゃないか
と思って探しました。
美術館で、横にいた学芸員みたいな人に訊いたんですよ。
「タマネギ持ってるおじさんいませんか？」って。
「タマネギ？知るか、そんなの」と言われて、
私ずーっと壁画見てたんですよ。
ついに見つけました、タマネギ持ってる人！
で、エジプトに行ったタマネギは、
次ヨーロッパに行って、そしてメイフラワー号に
おそらく乗ってアメリカの新大陸に行って、
新大陸から北大に赴任されたブルックス先生が
タマネギを日本に持ち込んだんです。
これが日本のタマネギの最初の栽培と言われています。
そんな、あんまり人気のないタマネギなんですけれど、
日本で一番食べられてる、作られてる野菜ってなんだと思いますか、量で？
お米とか小麦とかお芋とかちょっとおいといて、
生鮮野菜で一番たくさん作られている、
食べられている野菜は？
言ってくださいね、自由に！
タマネギって言いたいですけどね、3位だそうです（笑）
まだ上に2つありますよ。
（キャベツ）
キャベツいいですね〜！
キャベツ2位！
（トマト）（ネギ）
もうちょっと（笑）
1位ね、ダイコンだって！
（へー）
ちょっと意外ですよね！？
世界ではちゃんと統計がないんだけど、
一応言われているのは、
（豆！）
あ、豆もね、ちょっと置いといてください、
主食になるものは。（笑）
（タマネギ！）
タマネギね、2位だそうです。（笑）
けっこういいでしょう？